[Music]
thomas joins us up next in greensboro
north carolina thomas welcome to the
show
hey y'all thanks so much for having me
sure how can we help
i have one primary question and then the
second one if we have time for it but to
give you some context and background to
the first one
so
my fiancee and i are wondering if we're
about to spend a little bit too much on
a honeymoon or not so she is projected
to make about 28 i'd say about 32 000
this year she is a beautician she does
hair cutting
then i will make probably about a little
bit more than 45 this year i drive a
straight truck for a living i plan on
getting
my cdl probably the next two to four
months so that will also increase
my uh income
she has absolutely no debt whatsoever
and she has about i think three or four
months of emergency funds
i have a thousand dollars in an
emergency fund
i do have a little debt i have one
credit card with about 1500 bucks on it
that will be paid off by the
wedding our wedding will be in october
we're thinking about eight thousand
dollars for the wedding five of that is
coming generously from our parents and
then we're cash flowing the rest
but then there's the honeymoon we
were kind of wanting to take a little
bit longer of a honeymoon i i personally
haven't had a week over a week vacation
in about five years so we were thinking
about two weeks
and the grand total was probably about a
little over thirteen thousand so we'd be
going
we'd be going into it a little where are
you guys going
to the moon is this like an overwater
bungalow in fiji
well i wish uh so we will be going about
if if we can
afford it we would be going to
st thomas and the virgin islands for
about a week then we'd be coming back
home going to our state fair in north
carolina for about two days and then
going to the biltmore resort in
asheville for about three days so that
would all be paid for in cash as well
we'd be cash flowing that so
that was kind of my question we've been
making about 75 000 a year when we're
married together but we didn't we were
just trying to figure out you know even
though we were debt-free even though we
would have some a decent income if if
maybe we should back off a little bit
yeah i mean i don't know if i'm a
cheapskate but spending 13k on your
honeymoon an 8k on the wedding feels
backwards to me that's pretty wild it
does feel a little sideways that's like
the guy that buys the two thousand
dollar car and puts five thousand dollar
rims and tires on it just seems a little
bit backwards gotcha so i mean i don't
know what you spent on your honeymoon
john that not near that
the purpose of the honeymoon
you're going somewhere tropical there's
not that much difference between cancun
and and st thomas as far as you know a
nice view
so if i'm you i'm gonna do some heavy
research to go how can we cut this thing
down to three four thousand dollars and
still have an amazing time
yeah and yeah and
yes if you don't mind we we have done a
tad bit of research we did get a um
a person to look over things for us
it's really things like the flights that
are just killing us so again we've only
put the deposit on some of these things
so we can take it back
and uh from what you're telling us we
may end up doing that so
you can get all your money back
i believe so we've only put like three
or four hundred dollars on the deposit
and they're accountable two weeks up
until the arrival so okay so as as a guy
who's been married for a long time we i
just went to asheville for my 20th
anniversary so it's great place you put
you're picking well it's awesome
um
there is going to be some stress to
dealing with the wedding to getting
married to moving into a place together
even though we get all planned out we've
been dating a while we're best friends
we love each other all those things it's
just going to be a season of stress and
if you throw 13 000
go into this country then get home and
then go in here you're going to end this
two weeks more tired than you started
and then you're going to launch back
into work she's going to be back right
so you're you're setting yourself up
um to stumble at the at the starting
line
i would much rather you take a much
smaller a
less expensive not cheaper but a less
expensive
time for y'all to just be together and
rest and enjoy life have some fun do
some cool and rest doesn't mean do
nothing right but but rest means we're
gonna do some stuff it's gonna be cool
and then let's put a pin in it let's say
our five year anniversary or a three
year anniversary or our completely
debt-free anniversary we're going to st
thomas for two weeks and we're gonna
blow it out dude do that right and then
that's gonna be something i'll work
forward to y'all work for together and
it's not gonna be stressful on top of
stress on top of stress yeah i'm
probably gonna punt at the asheville
trip the biltmore trip to the spring and
just focus on this tropical trip maybe
do a week maybe eight or nine days and
uh check out costco travel that's where
i've personally booked my honeymoon we
just did a three year anniversary trip
to cabo we did it all through costco
travel and it was a fraction of what you
just described and it was all inclusive
we had a great time it was very relaxing
you never heard of costco sean is
writing down i'm writing it down let's
go travel yeah i'm telling you dude you
can get some great deals it'll include
flights there's a lot of great options
there
peanut butter and uh dog food i didn't
know you could get a costco travel trip
to mexico today we've got like virtual
travel agents that will help i was just
like hey here's my budget what's the
three best places to go they told me i
said what's the three best resorts on
each of those great you just saved me 14
hours of research
and i just booked it i'm in so that's
what i would encourage you to do thomas
congratulations on the wedding that's
fantastic uh but 13 grand goodness
gracious that's some that's some bougie
lifestyle right there to go back to the
fair and eat fried oreos